hello everybody before we get started I
want to let you guys know that the
tickets for the tour are on sale now if
you go to markiplier comm or the link in
the description below because the same
place you can find all the cities that
we're going to and all the ticket sales
are right there on the website check it
out let me know what you think and
thanks for watching here's the video
seizure warning this game has a lot of
flashing colors and lights no joke lots
of them
big seizure warning pigs can be hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to V now this game is
interesting just because Oh Fred Green I
like that show and it was on the TV
channel tube thing blue I'm feeling blue
cyan okay purple yellow red
okay alright okay alright okay
ah I get it I'm supposed to left-click
when it's the right color to the right
name and right click when it's the wrong
to the right okay oh did I pass the test
fee did I pass the V test okay all right
well don't come any closer please don't
do that okay oh you are a gifted child
sitting in front of a TV screen am I now
don't call me a child you we use your
intelligence to switch through every
channel on the planet Oh America Samoa
achievement unlocked uh
the cookies blue no no cyan ah hey goof
did V I'm sorry V I'm so sorry
Oh achievements connect to Oceania oh no
no oh no this is deeper number three the
cookies I don't know I don't know what
nausea does but I keep it on I guess
No okay here we go connecting to Oceania
let's do this red cyan no yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes no yes yes
no yes yes my brain is pricking my brain
is breaking oh no no oh I got to Asia no
yes yes no no no yes No
oh my god my brain yes oh my god okay I
I couldn't quite tell what that one yes
yes yes yes no yes yes yes oh [ __ ] that
was really green Oh TV Oh TV number 50
oh man I got too old man oh my god okay
here we go
I gotta go through Oceania again Oh blue
yeah okay yeah okay
all right yep Jeffers yeparooni yep
padiddle
yep andö yep an ebow nope ah super yep
not yep yep yep yep yep yep or duper
duper duper nope nope yep II Duke yep
yep yep yep yep yep going asia okay if i
camp if I don't let my brain break and I
show how smart i is maybe I'm gonna get
something here yep okay no yes ah yes
yes yes yes yes no yes no yes
oh yes oh my god I almost messed up
there yeah freaky freaky yes oh my god I
don't know if I have a time limit on
this thing it's getting real nauseous in
here no yes no yes no yes yes yes yes no
yes yes no no wait oh you [ __ ] me okay
all right you don't know what you did to
me and why you did I'd DTV down to
victory
damn three no I mean it freaking big oh
well I'm almost completing the game in
do to achieve Sherlock mode what is
Sherlock mode I'm gonna turn off nausea
and also obviously there's a seizure
warning on this one it's turned off
nausea
cuz it's nauseous and started Asia I'll
do that thanks alright okay here we go
starting an Asian Al yellow green no yes
yes no cyan red no red blue
oh no no sighing red no yes yellow no no
no no no yes green no blue no red yellow
green yellow ah
Frick I don't like this very much it is
no no I'm clicking cyan no oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh god I don't know what
happened there but I think I did it
who's that Sherlock mode I sure didn't
feel like Sherlock
I felt like stupid I don't know that was
the thing I didn't know that was the
thing I went to Lithuania who's all the
way to Lithuania yes yes no no yes yes
oh yes don't know why is that why is
that going all crazy on me yeah okay
okay gotta go Detective Mode I know that
yes yes my pain is slowing down I can
actually feel my brain physically
slowing down and crippling doubt my
entire body Oh second chance I got a
second chance that's fine let's go let's
do this wait what does that mean what is
the second chance do didn't do nothing
did I have to click on it God that looks
blue ah it looks blue [ __ ] a doc oh god
I'm getting too quick about it my brains
not keeping up with my hand red yellow
green cyan No
oh no red cyan red no green cyan no no
yellow green no green blue green knows
oh this is our desired desired as hard
as hard as hard as hard
Oh God
right off the bat I didn't even get a
chance you can click as many times as
you need okay all right okay blue green
no yellow Connie looks blue okay I don't
know what that means inverted controls
it up okay all right you tried to [ __ ]
pool with me and I ain't playing your
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] there we go got it I
got you you think you got me but you
don't cuz I'm smart and you're dumb and
we're gonna win this and I'm gonna win
this and that's cyan that screen that's
red that's yellow that's red that's not
yeah it's over to the good [ __ ] in the
America is all right here we go inverted
blam got it inverted blam got it
inverted [ __ ] yeah no red green cyan no
red cyan
ooh I don't know what that was right
oh why my finger twitched ah okay who
[ __ ] man those inverted upside-down nose
ain't so I didn't do anything
ah Frick you are messing with me okay
goddamnit I love okay all right well
then hi ah ah
frickin freaking freaking frickin
Fricker Fricker Fricker Frick fricky
dick Africa Africa oh yeah not today
oh it always gets me inverted goddamn
controls yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah okay no no no no no no yes [ __ ] I
hate this
oh my god okay alright we're doing okay
yeah
[Music]
no I did it I did it I did it I did it I
did it I did it I did it oh I did it
holy crap I did it Oh reached number 200
on Saturn I don't know what that is okay
but that is the end of this so far I
think no I don't want to go back in I'm
gonna feel you okay all right so anyway
I'm gonna leave this at that before my
brain melts thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought is down in the comments below
this is super fun by the way it's it's a
weird skill it's one of those skills
like you don't think you'd ever need but
still it's really really cool so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]